hello there reject nation greg john
we're gonna watch the bad batch today
the bad batch kevin no one's trying to
snatch
omega who's being protected by wrecker
that's all i got yes this episode
something or another it's called rampage
starting doing the rock johnson look
guys not many people watch
our reactions for this so we could say
whatever the heck we want in an intro
hey hit that like button if you think
chris pratt is innocent
if not hit the like button subscribe
and uh check us out on patreon we do
full-length watch alongs
for all the guardians of the galaxy
movies we do reaction highlights for
tomorrowland
as well and oh no i mean the tomorrow
war this is a great show
i've seen a couple star wars movies
before so i feel like for the most part
i understand what's happening
shouts out to uh baba frick and
jar jar biggs and kylo
kylo ray reylo yeah that's not a
character
i'm sorry oh oh you mean oscar is fake
nerd yeah
dj from uh the last jedi
roseanne little boy it's roseanne's
daughter son really
yeah it's becky dj
what's the other good daughters roll
that intro thanks to predominant for
editing that's
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's not an exact fit i get my own
calm device technically it was
crosshairs but you're the new crosshairs
there
why are we going to ordmantel i thought
the plan was to lay low
not while a bounty hunter's after you we
need to find out why
i know an informant there named sid
stewart squats
well the jedi trusted him the jedi who
are all dead
the jedi worked with this guy sid was
that
sid sid
like toy story is actually a crossover
character
just gets blipped into a different
dimension
this is the place cyberpunk 2077.
hey i forgot the name of that creature
comment below just keep an encyclopedia
here we're looking for sid
you know him sit huh
nope doesn't ring a bell what about them
was i not clear you're in the wrong
place the jedi came here during the war
well
perhaps sid heard what happened to the
jedi and fled
what's your deal tiny you're sid
yeah you're sharper than your friends
over there
did the jedi have other informants
i really figured this out
she forced she's got before sensitive
it's like a western thing going with the
jedi
they valued my insights but now that
they're
all dead the demand for my services
has declined thanks to this new empire
close that clone war helmet in the back
tell me what you want
what you want you what you want we
encountered this woman on pantora
do you know who she is no but i know a
bounty hunter when i see one
can you find out who hired her that
depends on what you boys do for me
make love that's the only thing to do
you pull a job for me
and i get the information you want what
kind of job
a rescue there's a nice bounty on a kid
named
moochie they're a bad bantha piece
panther horn maybe the thing behind
bring me the kid
and i'll get you your intel who collects
the bounty we split the bounty
70-30 my favor take it or leave it
grab a kid from a few zargarians
we could do that not sleep looks like we
have a deal
that was a trustworthy smile
[Music]
you all right yeah yeah yeah it's
nothing
well that
that's a lot of attention i think
something's going on
with the chipping buys and sells people
for credits
people can be sold they don't have a
choice
they're captives treated like property
i was cheap don't worry moochie we'll
rescue you
if you rescue me
who does this rescue me counting one
republican one republican does that say
[Music]
she looks scared simple smash and grab
like that time on kuat
easy enough i'm in what are we waiting
for
you get back to the ship but that's an
order
yes sir
you know what to do disobedient time to
rebel omega
you know john you really take this
animation for granted it looks great
should hear what he says when we're not
filming
geez these terrible renderings
[Music]
oh no um two roving patrols on speeders
first guard checkpoint dead ahead what
the hell
uh hang on i think i got company i'll
take care of it
[Music]
i'm making some alterations to my
trooper now she's a bad bitcher
what do you think we bound their [ __ ]
am i gonna say it sounds like she said
bad bad [ __ ] yeah okay
that's exactly that was the original
dialogue and then they had to find
one he's a bad bitcher
come on solid snake hide in a box
well now she has a reason not to stay in
the ship absolutely now it's smart
[Laughter]
we're returning to base ship
is clear i want to kill
someone today
okay now you can go back to the ship
hunter do you copy
tick echo ricker anyone
crosses where's my bad [ __ ] at
[Music]
even bigger escape heist
it's getting looser yeah
hmm i i feel like we've seen that
creature in clone wars before
we need to signal omega before the
scouts find her
except our calms are over there with our
weapons
[Music]
we won't need a calm to signal her
[Applause]
look at what we have oh i just got a
kink in my neck
just to add to my collection you should
fetch a nice price
the republic outlawed slavery we're not
in the republic anymore
skug you're lucky we don't have our gear
because this should go very differently
for you
our gear located over there where you
put it a few minutes ago
right there very thin pointing with my
nose
it'd be a shame if someone would have
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happened
we can make do with one last slave
maybe i'll feed you to my pet nice
hmm as for the rest of you
sales goes i just want to see wrecker
like gore is way out of the beast's
chest
but pg style yeah yeah green goo and
the creature's fine off-screen yeah
flourish once again
i know no
is that a i'll just wait to see
but i think it is is it
let me gotcha i found her sneaking
around the cage
i wasn't snaking i was unlocking
tonight secure the cage
oh yeah it is
oh damn it ah this is the return of the
jedi
rancor record further encore yes yes
listen franco is not the distraction i
will thank you ted thank you you saved
us tonight
this tech has seen all the star wars
i said adolescent is it the same one
maybe i wouldn't put it past him
it's okay moochie we're here to take you
home
uni nagamuchi muchi
[Music]
no way look at him go
moochie moochie go on mooch
gear up we have to go after moochie we
don't capture her
we don't get our intel from seat
wow way to go moochie
i love it it's a record that's hilarious
[Music]
she's doing fine on her own ha ha see
you later out of the cage
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh come on moochie
no chief
yeah just the two of you go get mooch i
feel like moochie's harder to get in
this game yeah
oh
oh
awesome flawless victory
come on give me some wilhelm scream
anywhere i'll take it
[Music]
no way whoa wait she got herself a
[Music]
weapon
this is like a kaiju fight yeah
oh i feel bad for whoever's losing it at
any point
any ideas how to stop that thing rancors
adhere to a social hierarchy
you have to challenge the alpha for
oh that authority could do
what did you think you were gonna do
come on wrecker
oh yeah come on record come on buddy
wrecker versus rancor
bye it's not that's how you say it
boy boy boy
oh moochie moochie looking tired
let's go round two mooch
respect me already nicely handled
wrecker
yeah right that's fine
what a pleasant surprise embraced by the
present
no way is it the same one
yeah i would not doubt that at this
point that's messed up
bib relax i always deliver on my
promises
you'll see
i told you this is a delicate mission
tell jabba to be patient i like that
she's from the new york part of the
galaxy
i know everyone but jabba who's that
it's the bikini chick from one of those
[Laughter]
right
that breaks my heart i can never look at
return of the jedi the same way
you're going to shed a tear next time
you watch it
this poor rancor
i love you i wasn't sure you could pull
this job off
you could have told us we were going
after a rancor
hmm must have slipped my mind
you doc and broody my office
they're all dark and brody or pale and
broody
yeah i guess so everyone accept echo yes
who hired her unknown my sources in the
guild say she's working on a direct
commission
with someone like our nipping at your
heels you're gonna need two
things friends and money mostly
money well we're not swimming in either
at the moment
i guess it's a good thing you met me
then isn't it
here's your cut there's more where that
came from
if you're looking for work how much is
it
it's interesting the bounty hunter of
fenix caliber being after you
you fellas must be pretty valuable
don't worry i'm good with secrets
[Music]
you [ __ ] i'll fight you right here
dude but if moochie is the one from
return to the okay
look why are we wasting our time here
can
someone in the comments just confirm or
deny
whether or not that is the one from
return of the jedi and i know it won't
just be one comment
it'll be like 50 to a thousand of people
saying no it's not you're wrong
i looked it up on the wiki fandom or
some [ __ ] next time just search the
comment thread and see if your comment
has been posted
and liked like a hundred times in this
case i'm a-okay
with everyone i just want just want to
know for sure
because that would be pretty messed up
if we could get everyone to comment the
answer that would be some
some great engagement i don't want to
watch the next time watch true did i
want to be like no change
look you don't understand there was so
much muji buchi was
imprisoned and so no
she never asked for this life moochie is
a victim of circumstance
moochie is pawn in game of life
at least the way it's presented here
makes it seem that way
well yes and in a sh in a universe that
seems apt to
bring up you know characters and then
you know pay them off down the line or
have the
show we need the mics we need the
microphone
don't worry i remember where you stopped
talking yeah
we don't need the sound from the mics we
just want the mics in front of us we've
never turned these on they don't work
they're not real
that we're saying moochie
is my new favorite star wars character i
feel so
sad for moochies troubling circumstances
we get your podcast breathing
just breathing sounds stare at each
other and breathe
for the next minute make everyone's hair
stand up on the back of their neck and
their
arms people keep making jokes about asmr
it's a finally time to make it real
dude this is the most important episode
we could have watched absolutely
so so much changed well i think it is
alluding to something
[Music]
indulge me okay i think it's leading to
them
leading a life of just being straight-up
mercenaries perhaps
bounty hunters they're not going to kill
fennec shand
no that's not possible and i don't think
fennec shan is going to kill any of them
no so i think
somehow they might even end up becoming
bounty hunters themselves
maybe them joining the guild or doing
some like mercenary gigs like this
first certainly seemed like a setup for
that because they need money
because yeah there's like some things
that here that just seem to be reminding
me
mandalorian as it progresses oh yeah
yeah yeah
bringing the guild and all that stuff
the guild
fennec little girl protecting uh
going on doing these random odd jobs
like i need to
get more information i'm trying to get
to this place well if you want to
do that well you got to do a job for us
first and having to do
jobs just to get an advance of
information yeah wrecker go take out the
mudhorn
i mean rancor i mean danjarin go take
out that mud horn
yeah exactly uh so stuff like that so
it's it seems that's the path it seems
like it's heading
and then every episode it'll just have a
little bit of record going oh
my head but i'm fine nothing to see here
tech and echo just being like i'm sure
it's nothing
of course nothing especially after what
happened across here is it can't happen
again
yeah twice especially tech
being all knowledgeable about this about
technology i want to worry about that no
no
hey he got out in the field for a hot
second today too tech dude
doing something his ass whooped like
right away yeah but you know
he showed up and wasn't just on the ship
doing something
uh but yeah man the this is fun episode
but you can't get past moochie i know
why mooch let's just look it up
let's just look it up yeah it means
what's the way to google this is the
raincore
in bad batch the one
from
muchi isn't java's rank
[Music]
no why because there's i mean that's the
first one from
comic cbr but then there's a whole bunch
from
hours before this one came out hours
before so i guess like there was a lot
going around
yeah i mean you could just [ __ ] say
some [ __ ] you could
just like like people seem really upset
about the [ __ ] the mooch is the wrinkle
from return the jedi
yeah i mean well why isn't it i mean
maybe they just like collecting
rancors funny maybe yeah it's the same
associates of jabba the hutt but just
you know
one of many rancors in their stable
muchi the baby rancor is female while
rancor luke fights
and kills as a male named patissa
i'm not gonna lie they don't look any
different to me and batista other than
patisser's
huge ass ningling that is so distracting
when he shows up to fight luke
oh my god get that on my face that's
what he fights luke with yeah yeah yeah
luke accidentally wins lightsaber versus
a rancor wayne
get away
i could just change the name yeah java
could have been like i
don't like your name yeah i don't like
your girl name i'm gonna name you a guy
thing
no one will be able to tell if i gender
you this way
that's a bummer now i'm bummed i guess
i'm i'm slightly relieved but also
bummed because now there's no easter egg
it's just another rancor
watch these for references only
[Laughter]
i mean i we could spend the whole
discussion talking about this because
one part of me is like wait a minute
what's the why would you suggest this to
me don't you know what he said like
right on you got tuna showing up at the
end there
with his uh gamorans
gamma gamma rayons i'm sorry i gotta
clearly uh haven't slept much
the uh gamma naughts gamorians i think
they're called gammarians
in the gomorrah yeah
you know any if this was if this was
yesterday i would know it
i think it's gamorean i think it's good
yeah check this one but
yeah the gamoreans are there so it just
makes you think that must be the one
from return of the chat
all these visual yep gamorian there you
go
cues so um
yeah to do that and then to just
have all these things come out going
it's not don't
let your feelings get hurt when you want
to turn to the [ __ ] maybe this is
exactly why they did that though maybe
because they knew they would get us all
going who's that the same one
and then you know we'll find out and do
this yeah all together
anyway other things that happen in this
episode omega it looks like she got a
little arrow event uh
yeah like on horizon horizon zero dawn
yeah yeah yeah like a laser crossbow or
something like that
yeah and she she went back to the ship
for real and then had a real reason to
need to abandon it
i pretty sure i saw the dragon thingy
and uh
i have an image in my head of like
anakin writing it at one point
there you go that's how you do easter
eggs and breakdowns
i have a vague recollection that this
could have happened maybe if we did that
these drugs would break then i'd be like
go only off memory
no research not even pulling something
up on the other screen man
those easter eggs and breakdown people
who we love
obviously we really do the only thing we
react to you never
you the way they talk about it makes it
seem like
they just know yes look at that it's
this person
yeah there was no fact checking involved
there was no verification
yeah there was no organization of these
points
that's why i would love to to uh that's
but associated with breakdowns it's off
memory
and this this is like dragon looking
creature thingy i'm pretty sure
we've seen that before i have like a
vague image in my head
of anakin on it that it could be a
mistake
different dragon perhaps definitely yeah
but i'm pretty sure it's the one
like and subscribe for more great
breakdowns
easter eggs and everything you missed
we're doing it now this is a pleasant
episode but
i guess i gotta admit you know last
couple haven't been like
taught i think they've kind of dipped a
little bit in
enthusiasm for me these past couple i
think the funny thing about the constant
sort of like this is kind of like the
mandalorian but with a group instead of
one guy it's like a 20-minute version of
the mandalorian instead of keeping it
personal i'm one or two characters it's
a bunch you got to keep cutting too
and out of a show that i can tell is not
10 episodes but more like 25
yeah so yeah it doesn't feel as
propulsive
in the progression of the story i guess
it feels like it would have benefited
from uh
but then again you know like clone wars
uh
i didn't watch it in release date
order you watched it in like timeline
order
yeah i think disney has it at like a
chronological or like the episodes got
released in a weird mess
like a weird way that happens in most
shows it does hey
it doesn't happen as egregiously third
season of friends came out first
before no but there have been shows in
the past where like they're an episode
out of order and
and then you know certain circumstances
do not
jibe quite or there will be a detail
where you're like what was that about
then four episodes later you find out
what that was about
yeah so uh uh what were we talking about
before
this technicality thing got brought up
for this unnecessarily long discussion
uh we were getting okay but clone wars
uh clone wars is the same the same thing
a bunch of episodes per season
uh you sometimes you like spend a few
like okay this these few you're
definitely like with the soca for a year
and then this view you're definitely
with these like these people you might
not even cut to
these other characters and then here's
like
always with a bad batch right yeah so i
i don't think it's short of being
gripping and it is still the first
season and it it's just like the
the first episode was so strong
so strong yeah and then i really like i
think it was a third one
uh that was great too and then getting
fennec involved is cool and everything
and like the
it's exciting uh but
it was like all right okay whatever but
this one was
it really the most exciting part to me
was wondering if that's the same range
or from return of the jedi
yeah i i don't know what it is because
there's a certain
episode kind of went down a tad bit for
me
it's been kind of up and down from none
of them have been bad i just have
they've gone from like exciting and
gripping to
kind of that was an episode yeah yeah
yeah just sort of like a transitory like
okay we're gonna get to the next thing
and you know hopefully maybe the next
episode will be super gripping or super
rollicking or whatever but
yeah i mean this definitely felt sort of
like
a side quest and because you know you
have at least 10 less minutes than your
average mandalorian episode it does feel
i guess kind of brief
and uh you know in terms of stakes and
whatnot i didn't feel
a heap ton of peril i guess which i
might have wanted to feel given that a
rancor is still a lot to deal with
you know look like a disney junior
rancor
kind of yeah it's an adolescent rain
course that makes sense
i guess i just appreciate i like this
show better and i feel the same way with
clone wars like i like it better when it
really feels like a dark
show yeah yeah yeah dealing with the
kids yeah i mean this is a
definitely like a fun and bouncy
adventure episode but yeah at the same
time
yeah for my adult mind when they're
dealing with the implications of the
rise of the empire and the weird
interpersonal stakes that that raises
for everybody
you know in the dark circumstances that
that bego all begets
is when i've been the most scripted by
this show yes yeah because they're like
captured you're like
all right they'll be fine
especially for this like side mission
where it's like you know you got these
people here
who don't seem overly threatening beyond
just
kind of wanting to keep their prisoners
here you know
it's still fun though like yeah it's
like fun and enjoyable but it didn't
feel
ultimately like like a very substantial
episode i guess
and then to find out that moochie is not
the same rancor it almost feels like
they
they added the gamoreans and and for and
tuna in there
to make us have an added layer of like
care or something to
talk about whereas like if it was just a
regular rancor and then two random
other alien races showed up to pick it
up we might not be having that i mean
the fact that when i type
in that question there are so
many so many articles about it
it's clearly the most talked about thing
from this episode
it's probably and then for them to be
like but it's not it
doesn't that kind of undercuts it a
little bit especially
it's it's strange yeah because it seems
certainly visually set up to make
you draw that connection yeah if you
know it you know
and then to have it be something that is
so easily i guess disproven is
is is funny to me and again i i start to
wonder like
are they just messing with us because
they know they're
gonna try and extrapolate an easter egg
from that or whatever
but then again you know if that's the
case
that's distracting because it's the most
notable part of the episode
i mean it's like you can't win with the
record
yeah because if it is and it's like
that's pretty messed up man the loot
kills moochie
and then the others are all they went
through but that's kind of interesting
too it is and then then you find out
it's not
and then you're like what was porn like
doing all that
yeah i mean cool they got a different
rancor for something else they want to
use but
again like in a in a series that seems
again not even just this series but in a
franchise that seems apt to be like
remember this thing and here's the
origins of that thing
yeah i'm surprised that they did this
that's what stresses me out
long head or those what was called long
hair you just come to me
moment of truth here long ahead
bicep exercises
no it's just darth vader's you got a lot
of different results from
from long yes
ki adi mundi that's who we're trying to
get to
this is a general description of a bunch
of different star wars characters
but what's at the beginning when the
before they found sid
oh what the [ __ ] were those called oh
yeah i don't have it i am not enough
for nerd to have it look at the photo of
it right there
it's good oh where to go did you see it
john find it did you find it i know it's
not a sign for you guys but
this is our we're just kidding this is
the suspense we have this whole
discussion here
yeah and not here
right there okay yard barker
yard barker huh interesting
the character's name or the type of
creature oh man i didn't know that at
all
[Laughter]
yard of barker star wars
no no yard barker
what the hell okay scroll down in this
in that in that
sidebar there a little bit no no on the
side
where the picture is and then
one of them had like a name in the title
it was exiled oh no okay aethorian
bad batch this is why we got stands for
the mics
to free up all this research like this
unidentified
ethorian is that it the one in the bar
it kind of looks looks like it right
yeah yeah sure does
definitely a thorian this is not a long
head
long head definitely it's not a generic
like i don't expect along it
now people know which one it is well
it's the one with the long head
oh nice perfect i'm trying guys i'm very
close every time
you're killing it don't worry you're
doing way better than i am then i
than i could hope to even properly pull
rancour at the time
it's okay but you knew what him he knew
yeah i think i needed to
jog your memory probably you did i
needed you
you needed to get me thinking of the
original trilogy yeah
because then the the most recent star
wars that i have seen are
are just two of the prequels so you know
that's not the freshness to have in your
mind
the last star wars movie i saw was
the rise of ewoks that is the definitive
story best we need to know the origins
how'd they get there
let's say 25 minutes have people think
like what the [ __ ] needs to talk about
what did they do
in this breakdown this was the most
substantial episode of the bad bad she
had it i spent three minutes of
silence and muttering trying to figure
out the name there's a lot of
googling and tapping and keyboard clicks
all right guys we're done with life
listen
um you could find my tombstone over in
north hollywood just out in the middle
of an
empty lot couldn't get an actual
cemetery plot
subscriber real rejects click the
notification bell i don't think you're
gonna follow us on patreon
but if you do we extra duper duper super
appreciate it there's always that one
person who's like i hate when you take
the piss
out of my shower i hurt when it turns
this
is my tongue this is my tom hardy
subraction
guy it's like tom hardy
actions just your face is too visible
you'd be full tom hardy i'm
[Laughter]
get ready for that in venom too
thanks guys i think we're finally
[ __ ] done all right i'll see you guys